you
welcome to all of you my name is Paul
license records regarding society and
some public lectures by Gary Huck
entitled rifle cartoons in the labor
movement as history and of course I want
to begin by welcoming our computer Gary
puck want to welcome all of you the
audience and especially thank you for
coming to this miserable weather
place and I was imperative maggie scott
around here parking with us
co-sponsoring this event at well to
workshop that we're doing this weekend
to the cartooning blushing students that
I was leading and for us it's kind of
nice as in
can't be there can't hear okay in both
cases of we love the idea of pairing
formal public lecture with a workshop
afterwards to kind of joint theory of
practice and theory and we're looking
forward that's about as we can go Gary
so to introduce Gary he is a cartoonist
with the United electrical radio machine
Workers of America which is of course
independent progressive national union
based in pittsburgh PA right here I
Gary's the only cartoonist I understand
to be employed full-time by a labor
union in the United space at present in
Gary's work is distinguished in many
ways in addition his work has appeared
in Business Week Washington Post
Pittsburgh City Paper Center for
American Progress and a wide range other
publications gary has exhibited
nationally and internationally including
in the 1199 gallery in New York the
salute the salon of cartoon art in san
antonio cuba and museum of cartoon art
and in san francisco here in Pittsburgh
gary has exhibited his work at the
Warhol Museum the mattress factory and
the two museum Andy re has also curated
seven exhibits of cartoon are the
pittsburgh-based organization art up and
together with his partner in syndication
as he says Mike Kona paki who's
recognized up here as well Gary hunts
work has been tholla gize din 6 cartoon
collections many of the original
cartoons are in the permanent collection
of New York University's tanaman
Institute library and the Robert of
Wagner labor archives and one last a
sort of personal anecdote Gary cut
because recently had a great personal
effect on me we were at a previous
evening event in December and you know I
was wearing this leather jacket which I
got I used
store about 15 years ago it's probably
already about 200 total I've got it and
one of my most cherished possessions and
Gary approached me and said you know so
it's paraphrasing he said something like
that jacket is so 80s question think
about maybe getting a new one sometime
several people had said similar things
to me my wife on numerous occasions
that's me but you know coming from a
radical labor cartoonist sighs okay the
time has finally come to change my job
so I did in on in Gary's Honor I
actually brought no jacket I'm wearing
it for the first time this evening so
this is just one small way of radical
arsonist has changed the world these
will learn that there are other even
more perhaps more significant ways as
well both of the present an historically
speaking that radical labor cartoonists
have tried to transform the world in
other ways and as I suspect that Gary
Huckle conveyed his talk today the
radical cartooning the point is not
merely to draw the world but to change
it and so let's all welcome Gary on
behalf of anyone who actually have seen
Paul in that jacket you're welcome
welcome to oh sorry that was my michelle
bachman impersonation i would like to
thank the Center for Arts in society and
CMU for this most ironic venue my
chronic kept my kata back he couldn't be
here he lives in Madison Wisconsin and
he's boycotting Pittsburgh until the
Super Bowl issue is resolved what I like
about cartooning is you don't have to be
there when they happen so speaking at a
venue like this you'll have to forgive
me if I'm just the wee bit awkward
because I'm used to having my work speak
for me and not having to speak for my
work but since i'll be speaking for the
work of other cartoonists cartoonists
that probably reputations have been
injured by their association with the
labor movement but in many ways are
responsible for what contemporary
political cartooning looks like so I'm
hoping by the end of the slide show
you'll have appreciation for for the
truly innovative and great minds that
once contributed to this labor movement
and hopefully you'll also understand the
awkward wording of the title that was
intentional we're going to start with
this image that is attributed to Paul
review you're probably saying Paul
Revere wasn't a labor cartoonist and he
wasn't but and he didn't even draw this
because Paul Revere was an artist either
and if you research the history of this
particular image which is the Boston
Massacre you'll find out that Paul
Revere was sued for using the image
because it was actually done by an
artist named Henry Pelham who was a Tory
and but it is important partially
because
some of what I'll be talking about is
how cartoons and how technology affects
cartooning so if you look at really old
prints you'll see that there's usually
the mark of the artists and the mark of
the engraver and because Paul Revere was
a silversmith he actually engraved this
work and he did it to promote the
revolutionary idea that was hoping to
take hold in America and the Tory artist
drew it so he could be sent to England
so the English could keep track of how
many colonists they've killed lately and
also it helps me because I'd like to
just briefly say I was at a party once
years ago and this gentleman said to me
after he found out what I did he said
you know if if you change the name to
something more serious people would
probably take what you do more seriously
as he thought cartoon by definition was
of was a was a simple word or a silly
word and so anyone here that's in the
arts knows the the origin of cartoon is
of course the drawing that is often
prepared and transferred to a painting
so the word cart in cartoon come from
the same thing to carry over so the word
actually has a very good pedigree thank
you very much this is often considered
to be the first political cartoon drawn
by Benjamin Franklin 1754 the call for
the colonies to join excuse me the use
of the rattlesnake and for the colonies
was a direct result of there being lots
and lots of rattlesnakes in the United
States when the colonies moved in and
you know they are always turning up
places people were getting bit there was
a it was a very dangerous animal they
have crawling around so of course it was
eradicated along with the native peoples
so that didn't go over well okay and the
the image of the snake you might have
seen lately and I'm trying to remember
where we are where did I see the image
where did I see the image we are aware
did I oh yes the Gaston flag that has
been co-opted by the Tea Party which of
course the Tea Party was co-opted by the
GOP I would just like to say that being
grumpy about Obamacare does not a
revolution make so I woulds argue that
the second American Revolution was the
labor movement I would argue that when
the colonists faced the King of England
and said that we are your equals that
was a radical thought the idea that the
King no longer served by God was being
recognized by people that people had a
right of existence outside of this
god-given right to rule was a radical
idea and the idea of workers standing up
to robber barons and saying that we have
a right to benefit from the system was
an equally radical idea a lot of people
probably don't know is that since the
people like Carnegie couldn't claim
because of their meager beginnings that
they were chosen by God like kings and
lottery winners often do they they chose
to misinterpret Darwinism so Carnegie
actually thought of himself as being
more highly involved than in those
workers because really if the workers
were his equal then why weren't they as
rich as he was and so in a way
the labor movement was standing up to
this this a new kind of power that felt
it had a right to control their their
futures and their lives and this is a
this is that's part of what this story
is but part of this story is about the
artists that came to the aid of that
struggle and part of this story is about
how art is formed by technology and part
of this story is just about the unique
form of cartooning cartooning is this
weird combination of words and images
and and to me it has more to do with
images poetry than it has to do with art
and so as I go stumbling through these
images bear in mind i'm sort of
ricocheting between all these things
hopefully well okay where to start with
the Wobblies the Industrial Workers of
the world they were organized in 1905
and they're still around are there any
Wobblies here tonight you know I dreamed
I saw Joe Hill last night anyway on the
Wobblies were founded in 1905 in Chicago
at a convention of 200 socialists
anarchist and radical trade unionists
and they were there because they opposed
the limited vision of the American
Federation of Labor the AFL the afl-cio
still has a department called limited
vision and their offices in Washington
DC good okay I'll try to limit that as
much as I can but what can I do their
slogan was an injury to one that's right
they're getting better that's right in
hopefully I'll get better before we all
get gone an injury to one is injury to
all was the Wobblies slogan and the
Wobblies embraced art and music and
almost everything they did
and many of the truly innovative ideas
of cartooning came out of the Wobblies
so this is Ralph chaplain who also drew
under the name of bingo and he is 1887
to 1961 and he was a writer and artist
and labor activist he wrote this the
song solitary forever I will now sing
all 253 versus so salary forever just
kidding although there are people here
that could sing all verses of it he also
illustrated for the care publishing
company in New York which still
publishes radical books today and i'm
proud to say published the first three
collections of mine and mike connor
pakis cartoons this cartoon is a perfect
example of pretty much how not to draw a
cartoon except for the caption which is
just a wonderful piece of irony tearing
down the Chinese wall of capitalism did
you ever think you'd live and so anyway
labor of course is big and powerful
don't you know and and and he's got you
know he's got a banner one big union for
all workers there's a Sun coming up the
world for the workers it's rising and
he's tearing down the wall and all the
rocks are captured but it really it is a
kind of cartooning that certainly I
don't practice but it's basically to to
make the workers feel better about
themselves I do the kind of cartooning
that makes them feel miserable about the
way things are going but I can't help
myself and this is another cartoon by by
Ralph and if you can see what's going on
there the class conscious worker is
looking skeptically at this this puppet
show
and it's called the great hocus-pocus
game and and he's saying the the
capitalist who is controlling the
puppets saying vote for power into my
hands and I'll do the fighting for you
vote and be saved and and then the money
man behind is don't think he's wise to
the game yet so I wonder are we wise to
the game yet nope this is one of my
cartoons from the last election and you
know I could have thrown a but it was
the the gops turn to be corrupted by
money they take turns you probably don't
know that this this year Republicans are
corrupted more than the Democrats and
the elections coming up so then the
Democrats will be corrupted and so the
Republicans saying I owe you and the
money boss is saying I own you ok this
is the Wobblies rank-and-file members
contributed to cartooning and this is
included because it is a photo montage
and Sam is there is no history of Sam I
don't know who Sam was he's obviously
not a professional cartoonist but it is
really one of the earliest uses uses of
photo montage and it's also another
perennial labor symbol and that's the
big fist the big fist of Labor pounding
capital into subjection it works every
time this is cathy newman here hey Kathy
this is a linoleum block print and cathy
newman who is a professor here is a
practitioner of linoleum block prints
and very talented at that this is in her
work this is by CS zet sir and he drew
under the name of x 13 which was the
first three numbers of his wobbly number
I want to say that the history of the
knowing black friend part of the reason
it's used and it does create a very
simple and black and white which is how
i draw my black and white cartoons are
very high contrast but it also is very
inexpensive and the the Wobblies when
they were doing leafletting and things
like that they they couldn't really
afford to go out and get four color
lithography done which was used with
stones and transferring images and all
that so the linoleum black was a very
inexpensive way of doing it and during
World War two when the Nazis would limit
access to paper and access to ink and
access to everything and the conquered
nations many cartoonists would do
linoleum block prints they would get
dies from clothing and to make ink and
they would take linoleum off the floor
and cut it up and do their political
cartoons against the Nazis using that
this is the iconic image of Joe Hill who
was a poet the graphic artist oh but
that wasn't Joe Hill Joe Hill was the
organist as carlos cortez 1923 to 2005 i
actually was have the honor of having
met Carlos he was a poet a graphic
artist photographer euros and political
activists for six decades in the IWW he
spent 18 months in prison as a
conscientious objector during World War
Two his work and this is a woodcut but
he also worked in linoleum block was
very stylized there's a lot going on in
this print but it's a beautiful example
of of not going super realism which
you're going to see is is is a lot of a
lot of cartooning was done using super
realism so a lot of you're probably
saying well who was this
Joe Hill who I dreamed about just last
night he was a swedish american labor
actus activists and songwriter and this
is actually one of his drawings which
proves beyond a doubt that he was a much
better swedish american labor activist
and songwriter than he was a cartoonist
but again it's it's it's an ongoing like
the last few cartoons it's it's a
technique that we use in the ue during
organizing campaigns is you belittle the
boss you take this person who has all
this power and you either character chur
him or you put them in a position where
the worker is confronting them and as I
have two former a current editor and a
former editor and they can attest to the
effect that this this can have in
certain circumstances there's nothing I
enjoy better can I Minnesota tell a very
quick story i did a cartoon for GE we
represent GE workers and it was for
during a drug testing campaign and i
took Jack Welch who was a CEO at that
time and I put his image on the bottom
of a cup and it said how to promote drug
testing put the boss's pitcher at the
bottom of the cup and it was the only
time he ever objected directly to the
officers of the Union that he thought
that that was an outrageous use of his
of his image I disagree this is ernest r
eb who no one knows when he was born and
when he died he was German came United
States worked for the Wobblies for a
while and disappeared he created mr.
block in 1912 mr. block was one of the
first underground comics I would argue
and he's also the predecessor of Homer
Simpson he's a predecessor of any
character who gets himself in a fix in
this case this
Black is always misinterpreting he's
either sucking up to the boss and he's
always pays for it in the end and this
was just about the time when broadsheets
were being published and cartoons strips
were starting to to take place like
crazy cat for an example and the labor
movement was right there and mr. block
was a very popular strip I encourage you
to look up earnest and look through a
lot there's books of mr. block and
they're worth it they're very funny and
again humor that's a very important part
this is ryan walker he was a midwestern
ER populist socialist and he drew for
the Conrad the National ripsaw the
coming nation the appeal to reason and
the st. Louis Republic the reason I want
to mention that is that there was a time
in this country when you could be of
socialist you could be a communist and
you could work on a mainstream paper and
you and you wouldn't be fired or you
wouldn't be persecuted you just were
that's who you were and a lot of these
artists are going to see that went back
and forth between major publications
major galleries and their politics
unmolested until the dark days of the
50s and we'll get to that this is called
the political circus and the caption is
how long will labor remain in that
position straddled between the GOP and
the 99 years that's how long labor would
be straddling between the Democratic of
Republican Party case you were trying to
do the math this is also ryan is called
the rip shawn mother Goose jack and jill
plowed up the hill with blisters on
their feet to raise a crop for an idle
FOP who lived on easy street
a good thing we don't do that anymore
Ryan did Henry dub and Henry dub was
another version of mr. block and Henry
did exactly the same Henry got in a fix
Henry got kicked in the butt as he is at
the end of this car tuning for suffrage
this book was published in 1979 by Al
Shepard and and what a gift this was
because a lot of these cartoons had had
been lost and they were in archives all
around the country and she put together
into a book and I highly recommend it
this is Catherine Milhouse 1894 1977 she
was a highly regarded book designer
children's books and things like that
this was done as a postcard for women's
suffrage very nice style and so they use
this to send out the word around the
country this is Mary Taylor I had a
really hard time finding any background
material on her she's obviously an
accomplished artist it's a beautiful
drawing and so no me no vote means no
remedy for long hours in short pay and
so in 1920 I have to say it again 1920
in the United States of America it took
till nineteen twenty for women to get
the right to vote and so now women have
the right to vote how are they doing on
the right to choose oops what was right
to choose the chosen the choice chosen
by five men this brings us to the masses
The Liberator and the new masses one
magazine would close and the other would
open the
if you go on Wikipedia talks about how
innovative the magazine was because of
its graphics and it certainly is that
some of the best cartoonists to ever
pick up a pen or a grease cran came
worked for the masses but also amazing
writers like Macky max Eastman and John
Reed and it was published until nineteen
seventeen when it was closed down for
conspiring to obstruct conscription
which is not easy to say by the way they
were closed down taken the court because
they were interfering with the
government's need to draft and kill off
young men in world war one which of
course was a colonial war and you know
having lived through the Iraq war where
the news media bent over itself trying
to not offend the administration before
invading a country we didn't need to
invade it's interesting how freedom of
the press meets the need to make war who
wins this cartoon is by John Sloan John
Sloan is probably better known as a
practitioner of the ashcan school of
painting which was the super realism of
the era of painting what real life was
like an America art young who's the
cartoonist who saw at the beginning the
he actually said that the the school was
under the delusion that if you put a
garbage can in a painting or an ashcan
that that was realism this was the
Ludlow massacre was Colorado National
Guard attacked the tent city of 1200
striking coal miners and 19 people died
and this is john sloan 1871 1951 and
technology now is improving and this is
a lithograph so the original drawing is
done with an ink wash in greece cran on
a very porous paper which allows it to
be photographed and then that the
photograph is in able to transfer to a
plate and then it's printed so this was
a great innovation in cartooning and
this form of cartooning using the e
greece cran or ink washes dry washes on
on on pebbled paper would dominate
political cartooning all right up to the
60s this is robert minor a radical
journalist as well as a cartoonist a
leading member of the American Communist
Party and he drew for the st. Louis
post-dispatch and he knew Drew for the
New York world and he drew for the
Socialist Party and this uh this
wonderful drawing which has such force
is a grease cran drawing on paper of the
1916 Westinghouse strike in East
Pittsburgh that ended with the National
Guard killing several workers so your
are you picking up on the theme that the
purpose of government and labeled
struggle able or labor struggles during
this time was to come in and kill
workers I mean this was was what
government was for so in that sense
labor did call for less government this
is one of my all-time favorite cartoons
this is one of the cartoons that led the
masses to to get into trouble and this
is Robert minor and it's called the
perfect soldier accidentally during the
Vietnam War Tony off the Pulitzer
prize-winning cartoonist for the
Philadelphia Daily News redrew this
cartoon
on it Iran and the Chicago sun-times and
of course although the Wobblies and
leftists and Chicago wrote to the paper
and said that this was a ripoff of
Robert minor and Tony who was is a very
original cartoonist and would never
intentionally steal apologize for using
it and pulled it from syndication and
the cartoon has never appeared again and
no longer because this is 1916 it's
right before the the masses was closed
down art young i want to say our young
was born in Monroe Wisconsin I can say
categorically that all great political
cartoonists are born in Wisconsin I
don't know why that is it's well I dunno
why it's so cold that you spend a lot of
time doing other things in this case
drawing radical art but he attended the
chicago academy of design and he worked
for the evening mail in The Daily News
in the Chicago Tribune and early in his
career before he started doing wonderful
work like this which the only caption of
this work is capitalism and I I really
think it makes an eloquent statement
that has yet to be refuted in the
excesses of capital unless something
recently happened that refuted it nope
early in his career aren't young drew
this and this was a pamphlet that was
printed and it was about the Haymarket
strike the Haymarket demonstration where
a bomb was thrown in eight police
officers were killed in a number of
civilians and so the there were
organizers and radicals and Chicago and
they round him up and they hung some of
them and they're never ever able to
really prove who threw that bomb
it was just attempt to stop the protest
it's it's it's own version the labor
movements version of Kent State kill
them and they'll stop protesting aren't
young once he became radicalized
apologized for his work that he did this
is example of art young and I want you
to look a little closely at the style
here because now you're seeing a little
more it's not really super realism you
it's the the boss is definitely a
character ature he's again it's the same
theme that if the workers were ever to
organize then the boss would be afraid I
don't think there's a lot of shivering
bosses running around these days but
it's a perfect example of how cartooning
was starting to move away from realism
and become stylized and and I would
argue was it's starting to enter into
the realm of cereal cereal sir realism
and this is a perfect example so this is
a child labor factory and the it's
surrealism right the the tiny child walk
climbing the ladder up to this monster
and dropping a profit into its mouth but
of course child labor has been
eradicated from the world and we don't
have to worry about that ever ever again
oops this is one of my cartoons Charlie
labor used in China toy supporting
equipment in game factories this is from
2008 and the one was saying oh my god
it's a real child and it's a little
china doll again this is art young this
is the cartoon that pushed the
government over the edge it's you have
basically the entire country dancing to
the two
of Satan so Satan is is leading the
orchestra to war and the minister is all
for Jesus and all for profit and it's
the editor of the capitalist a
politician the minister if this isn't
what happened that led up to the war in
Iraq if this isn't the dance that was
being done but I don't think we have to
worry about that again so they were all
taken to court in October of 1917 and
art young the cartoonist was so afraid
of what might come of this that he drew
this are young on trial for his life the
judge actually told art that if he
didn't stop sleeping during the trial
that he'd be held in contempt and art
young and his autobiography said that
was ok because he already held the judge
in contempt and so like I said before I
mean this was the end of it the United
States never ever got involved in a war
simply for profit except for well this
one time so again one of my cartoons we
shall mobilise our forces of the Persian
Gulf evildoers will not be exonerated
for their actions the United States will
always be prepared to protect our a
macaw
so this is a new masses and Hugo gelert
also drew for the Liberator and the new
masses in the masses near the end this
is entitled to Scott squirrels boys
there were nine black teenagers accused
of rape and the Communist Party in
double ACP contributed heavily to their
defense fund and they received quite a
few trials in 1932 of this Hugo
Gillard's work was removed from the
museum of modern art in new york because
of his participation in the Communist
Party and and they were afraid of the
ramifications of that but almost the
entire art community of New York
regardless of their politics threatened
to pull their work out of the museum of
modern art if they didn't leave Hugo
alone and they did this is William
dropper he was a cartoonist in a painter
and a muralist and he drew for the new
masses and this is a very interest this
is called the Liberty League it was
organized by conservative Democrats in
1934 is opposition to Franklin Roosevelt
who they consider to be a socialist an
odd point of history in 1934 General
Smedley Butler who was a highly
decorated Marine Corps general claimed
that the league was plotting to
overthrow the government and wanted
Butler to lead the coup there's
conflicting evidence about whether that
took place or not I suggest you research
it if you're interested there is a movie
called seven days in May with Burt
Lancaster and Kirk Douglas that deals
with that sort of information that
basically we're talking about Blue Dog
Democrats here and I'm happy to report
that there's really no crazies
running around this country today trying
to overthrow the government so we can
all rest easily except for I have to
read this because I love reading this
cartoon this is one of mine from the
last election so it's called trust me
and straitjacket GOP saying seacoast
secret socialists have taken over the
government illegal aliens are everywhere
there's one in my garden right now
terrorists blew up your job gays want to
start their own army deficits are
crawling all over my skin like spiders
show me a birth certificate isn't Sarah
beautiful don't tread on my blue suede
shoes I'm fair and balanced give the old
to Wall Street Obama can levitate your
taxes I'm not in which I'm not a crook
I'm a little teapot corporations are
people I have millions of secret admirer
/ donors I'm mad as hell this is a CID
Hoff just two people recognize it off
yeah so anyone who is been a child has
everyone been a child Howard I doubt
that okay I spoken Howard's parents and
they categorically state that he was
never a child um sid Hoff was a very
famous illustrator of children's books
and he drew for The New Yorker and
Esquire and he also drew for the new
masses and this is a example of his
cartoon and it was called the upper
crust and and he's saying how can I
respect a man who likes a union bulldoze
him well before besides being a funny
cartoon is also a cartoon those drawn
after the Wagner Act was passed so
suddenly unions had a right to organize
in this country and suddenly all the
bosses that you were seeing early on
that were oh they were afraid the
Wobblies are coming to get us suddenly
the labor movement was coming not to get
them but to justly asked for their piece
of the pie so this this is a cartoon
about the the the switch and power in
this country and that powers up
abruptly come to an end in 1948 Charles
Wilson aji executives summarize the
political program a big business when he
declared that the problems of the United
States could be summarized as Russia
abroad and labor at home and thus began
the red-baiting era and suddenly labor
was purged the radicals from its ranks
magazines ceased and publish newspaper
cartoonist were fired for having
associations with radical groups like
overnight this everything I've shown you
up to this point disappeared there were
no more radical car tunings in the
United States people were hiding under
rocks their careers in jeopardy except
for Fred right Fred Wright was a
cartoonist that I replaced when I came
to work for the ue he was the only
cartoonist drawing cartoons during this
era that stood up to what was taking
place and this is an hysterical cartoon
about what was happening so it says I
don't care what kind of communist you
are your Reds are all the same to me so
anti-communist union strike so the labor
movement and I mean we could have a huge
argument and I and I don't want to do
that here with my my friends from other
labor organizations but the labor
movement was afraid of his own shadow
the labor movement ceased to refer to
itself as what it is labor organizations
promote socialism labor organizations
are socialists organizations that's what
we are but you can't say that anymore in
America or you become red baited so you
have to come up with all these different
things to call yourself you know coffee
clubs or whatever you and and
fortunately the the ue was there to to
confront that and and in almost every
Union in the country matter of fact
every Union in the world would run Fred
Wright cartoons so there was every
reason to be
happy the labor movement did have Fred
this is one of his cartoons that
adequately I think describes surplus
value and so the gentleman hat saying
what did you tell that man just now I
told them work faster how much you pay
him twenty-five dollars a day where do
you get the money to pay them I sell
products who makes the product he does
how many products does he make and one
day a hundred dollars worth instead of
you paying him he is paying you $75 a
day to tell him to work faster huh but
the machines belong to me how did you
get the machines sold products and
bought them who made those products shut
up you might hear you great cartoon ok
and Fred wasn't alone i mean i have to
say that on he was the only cartoonist
drawing for labor movement but there
were other progressive cartoonists and
one of all my all-time favorite human
beings i was fortunate to get to know
Ali at the end of his life was Ali
Harrington Langston Hughes called Ali
Harrington the greatest African American
cartoonist I there's there's no dispute
there he came in late to the Harlan
Harlan Harlem Renaissance he created a
strip called dark laughter and dark
laughter was a single panel cartoon that
ran in the New Amsterdam in New York and
it it revolved on this character Bootsy
and for much of America Bootsy which ran
and blac publications all across the
country and then in life and look was
the first glimpse into african-american
life in America and an alley was was an
amazing cartoonist and this one I can't
can you see the caption he's saying your
brother Bootsy take this extra ham I got
here in case the gentleman of the law
decides this demonstration is too
peaceful anyone who's ever participated
demonstration knows exactly what
that means unfortunately Ali was red
baited while he was doing work for the
n-double-a-cp because of his membership
in the Communist Party he left the
United States in 1951 and moved to Paris
with Richard right he was traveling
around Europe to different publications
that he worked for and was caught behind
the Berlin Wall and he lived in East
East Berlin any but he drew for radical
papers throughout the world when the
wall came down I actually got to to meet
him and in Detroit where there was a
show of his his work and he was truly a
gentle man in a deadly artist this is
one of his cartoons he drew for the the
weekly world which is now monthly try
monthly every other year publication of
the Communist Party and it goes out to
all 12 of their members and this is it
free enterprise death writing free
enterprise and time's running out which
of course came true time ran out and
free enterprise collapse and what do we
do we fed the pig all the money we had
and I want to go back because really you
can't really talk about working class
art without talking about bill mauldin
he drew Willie and Joe during World War
two it was just 20 years old when he
started drawing it he would make brushes
out of sticks busy bee out actually with
infantry unit actually fighting the war
George Patton some involved into his
office and threatened to throw his ass
in jail for spreading descent and all he
did was draw cartoons that actually
captured what was like to be a soldier
fighting in Germany in World War two
it's a great man he won the Pulitzer
Prize you probably saw it for the the
cartoon of
the Lincoln Memorial Lincoln weeping
over the death of John Kennedy won the
Pulitzer for that and when he came back
from the United States you want to
Pulitzer for for the collective cartoons
he did for Willie and Joe and this one
Joe is being taken away by an MP and he
said I tried one of them
labor-management arguments with the
lieutenant and tenant named Atkins and
so we had to go dig latrines that brings
it to me Gary Hawk as we speak oh this
is the cartoon I did this year on title
Tucson and we all know what happened
there that was the tragedy that befell
Sarah Palin not too long ago it was an
awful awful what it did the Sarah I mean
excuse me I'm getting I'm getting a
little I mean she's she's such a
wonderful human being in any way but I'm
not alone so this is a show I put
together for the arts group art up I
encourage you to go to art org it's a
wonderful organization it's called
workplace funnies I did this this was up
during the g20 and I invited this is a
illustration by mike connor packing hi
khana pakana pakis official slogan is
work sucks so we celebrate the idea that
we should all be fared Paley paid fairly
and everyone should be treated well but
we all know that you know we'd rather be
out doing something else this is Kirk
Anderson he's a freelance cartoonists
and st. Paul Minnesota he used to be the
cartoonist for the st. Paul Pioneer
Press he was fired as the shrinking
newspapers are attacking the the
newspaper guild and and Kirk was fired
to show how serious they were in st.
Paul to get the guild to agree to a
contract Kirk is a brilliant cartoonist
this is one is the difference between
you and me as I see my glasses have full
and this is trimming the fat just a
beautiful drawing again now is a good
time to mention that the the new
technology now is basically Photoshop so
a lot of the cartoons are going to see
are the the sketch is done on tracing
paper scan in computers and then the
finish works done in photoshop and from
that finished drawing you can go to
animation you can do color you can do
grayscale you can do black and white so
the technology is now allowed
cartoonists to basically create an art
that they can then use for different
things this is clay bennett like Bennett
is Pulitzer prize-winning cartoonist who
now draws for the Chattanooga Times
repressed his style is recognized now as
being one of the most prominent if not
the most prominent political cartoonist
in America he he started using Photoshop
way early as a perfect example of his
wonderful wit one factory is still
hiring as the pink slip factory this
cartoon is I'm so jealous of this
cartoon and the caption is imagine
living under a dictator for more than 40
hours a week which talks to the working
conditions and most my constable who's a
Canadian cartoonist and most of his work
is done in animation you can all you can
tell the unionist in this crowd me the
smoothness of what we live with whereas
whereas my personal flotation device
you're standing on it aha ocean and
captain of industry constables I really
really encourage you to look up his
animation ser hilarious and they're not
all political some are just you know odd
thinking he's an odd guy unless you're
listening Mike you're you're not on
he's odd this is Carole Simpson Carole
Simpson are Bob Carol and Estelle
Simpson and they're one of the few I
think the only team drawing political
cartoons he writes the gags and she does
the drawing Henderson you're already
doing the job of three people how can
you possibly have time to join a union I
think that sums it up you can see their
work they have a Carole Simpson their
website and they live in Chicago this is
the best labor cartoonists in the
country right now Mike on Apache live
the privilege of syndicating with do you
recognize a crook who destroyed the
economy yeah was the janitor so and you
already have the Republican workplace
Bill of Rights freedom of speech over
the mouth freedom of the press hands
tied behind the back the right to
peaceably assemble hand cleft handcuff
the right to petition for regress of
grievances and again they're tied up
Mike Connor paki along with Howard's n
did a graphic history the people's
history of the American Empire this was
just a couple years before Howard's
death it was a privilege for Mike and I
to get to know Howard and this book is a
wonderful wonderful read i I really
implore you to to go out and buy a copy
as soon as possible and while you're
buying it you might consider buying any
one of the six collections of cartoons
by Gary aachen Mike on Apache um six
there are six collections in and if you
only get four it just doesn't look right
is aren't you this is PS Mueller PS
miller draws for The New Yorker and I
love PS Mueller on he's just the
quirkiest guy and George Bush like drove
him over the edge he suddenly got very
political and this is her of his pre
political where he's just you know
drawing about the nature
work cube ilysm and then this is after
he was radicalized and it's one of my
favorite cartoons of all time so the
Wall Street guy who jumped and if you
want my opinion not enough of them did
and the allen ginsberg looking guy is
holding up the sewer cap so he can fall
even farther it's a very funny cartoon
in no words love it this is Joel Pett
pulled Pulitzer prize-winning cartoonist
for Lexington herald-leader Lexington
Kentucky without a doubt joel is the
most leftist leftist cartoon drawing for
mainstream papers and but these toys can
hurt our kids right and you you see the
concern over LED pain and toys and yet
the child labor and other countries is
making the choice very powerful
statement I love this cartoon I should
have stayed in school I could have been
me how unemployment reached into the
middle class this is andy singer andy
singer is minneapolis minnesota he's
freelance cartoonists and I love Andy's
work because he does he draws about the
nature of work as work itself he wanders
into politics he draws on the
environment he actually spoke here at
CMU about his work on on green cities
and eliminating cars and he does a
wonderful slide presentation does your
job make you feel like a piece of meat
as a wonderful piece of work and this is
modern work accounting law our
engineering and I hope you noticed the
Spock like nature
wonderful cartoon this is Sidney
Wilkinson the Pulitzer prize-winning
cartoon of the Philadelphia Daily News
and the first woman to win a Pulitzer
Prize for cartooning and unlike the
women's right to vote she actually had
to wait until nineteen ninety-three yes
in a repetitive strain injury from
firing people and Sydney's a Quaker so
she did this cartoon and I sent her an
email I said you know Sydney you're a
Quaker and she goes not today so Obama's
choices to get our money back and
they're all these high young Q and then
the people's choice is Tony Soprano with
Bill Young is Billy here I see bill back
there bill is from Baden PA he's an
asbestos worker with an art degree and
he has a PhD in modesty he's produced
several graphic novels on labor history
it's hard hard bread com yeah yes I
encourage you to go there and bill is a
wonderful this is from 2000 I often have
to call up Bill and remind him who's
forgotten to sign his work it's me and
you pal and then of course they crash
and he gets the air bag and the workers
get crushed okay this is matt wuerker
and I actually wish I could show you
many of his cartoons but this cartoon is
so perfect to end with because it looks
so much like the first cartoon it's the
same basic style it's and so here it is
it's a chessboard the workers on one
side but if you look at the bosses side
he has the police in the front and the
financial institutions and the
government behind him facing the workers
who are playing chess with only pawns
so this is and so this is sort of where
we're at today so we're having a global
takeover by corporations we're having
Republican governors and Democratic
Governors declaring war on public circus
or public sector labor unions we have
teachers unions being attacked last
night at the State of the Union address
so my question to you to this audience
especially to young people in this
audience is where will the artists in an
electoral stand in this struggle will
they do like these artists have done and
stand with the working people or will
they stand with their backs to those
working people that's it
yes oh here I liked your last point I
really like to see all these 20 and i
think the understanding i think
political cartoons and the ones you've
shown you only have a lot of power now
the last election the recent like I
wonder if I have a question how much
political cartooning is done to defeat
the Republicans and the Tea Party and
how do you think the political
cartoonist did I would say footballers
election isn't it the worst election
since nineteen thirty-eight Oh easily I
mean so how well I answered by saying
first of all there are only 65 full-time
political cartoonists left drawing in
America which is down when I started
joining the cartoonist Association there
were 300 full-time political cartoonists
in the United States newspapers often
layoff cartoonists before they lay off
anyone else part of it is just the and
no offense to to my two editors here who
do have a sensitivity and understanding
of political cartooning although it took
a lot of work on my partner um that that
that of the cartoonists are often
sacrifices being fluff when in fact I
would agree with you there they're
probably one of the most powerful parts
of any newspaper of all so what happened
in America was in order for cartoons to
keep their job a lot of them switched
over to this kind of joke a day drawing
and this idea that that politics is like
some sitcom and the the people in the
government are characters in the sitcom
and aren't they ever so funny so the the
kind of cartooning you're talking about
the kind of cartooning that I hope I
practice is only practiced by
a fraction of those 65 remaining
cartoonists that really take on the hard
issues I how can I explain it o ignorant
remember the one who drew the two bosses
side by side hmm and one boss was happy
who in the workers were every bride
bride taken care of himself well and
then the other one neighbor together oh
my I not I mean obviously Union for us
guru bucks speaking of that who lose the
tea party people probably say your image
of the boss really worrying because the
Union people are united I mean I know
the value of that but with the tea party
people because they were very effective
when you say in this last election sure
and whom you say that really you just
change the title on that thing instead
of it being labor it could be political
pressure groups or something like that
we're not as political groups no I agree
i think that that that people in this
country have been voting against their
own self-interests for a very long time
and this election it was very apparent
and very disheartening to me how how
people bought into the Tea Party which
as far as i can see was nothing more
than the party of we're really angry I
mean they they're against things but
they are not for anything they don't
have the rand paul i don't know him well
you saw him I would say Rand Paul is an
extremist I mean they're they're i'm not
saying they're not thinking people but
there's always been whether it's a moral
majority there's all these groups that
we'll we'll sell the divide and and any
election yes it divided live yes and and
I also think both parties sell anger and
both parties sell hate but it's not an
equal this is not an equal economy the
Republicans are way way in the lead can
I take another question thanks hi Kathy
vairocina yeah you used to be I mean he
was never a radical though Bernie was he
drew for the AFL after the red-baiting
era as a matter of fact he drew
red-baiting cartoons against the ue
which um when I met Bernie I said hey
Bernie you drew red-baiting cartoons
against the ue and he said they made me
do it but Noah Bernie was he was a
perfectly he was pretty good at drawing
cartoons that promoted the post Red
Scare irri afl-cio political line that
supported the Democratic Party and all
that but he wasn't a radical ergo he's
not in the exhibit and the show yeah
yeah I have I have Bernie some of
Bernie's cartoons you want me to email
into you really I tell you you ok
clean that era a little bit i mean i
agree with you there just obviously a
lot less radicals are way too good i
think that at least in the papers of the
aisle TW that I've been looking at
there's more radicalism there than be
remembered in the UH ok I'm going to
look at it again but cartoons but I mean
in the general strike of 1958 I hung out
of burden in DC somewhere shortly before
his death we had a lot to talk about but
yes I will I will take that under
advisement on perhaps i will be
introduced them to the slideshow the
future date yes Oh
I'm just curious i understand what he
did including him but you included
maudlin the beauty with her blah but her
Glock style seems to me so derivative of
that look that the new masters yeah and
I wonder if it was any if there was any
either or district or political is
exactly right so it goes that there's no
I mean now for the first time they're
actually teaching cartooning and college
the way almost all of us came up is we
would look at what cartoonists were
drawing so when when her block was
looking at as a young cartoonist what
was being done he saw grease crayon
drawings and he copied that style I know
for a fact that her block was a huge fan
of art Young's and so there's yes I
would say and then after I mean when her
block was drawing in her block was the
most prominent political cartoonist of
the mainstream press and a brilliant
cartoonist almost all other cartoonists
copied his style hoping to capture just
a little bit of his success and it
wasn't until which I didn't mention and
I should mention the when I started
drawing cartoons my background was a
little different I I Love New Yorker
cartoons I love Bugs Bunny cartoons I
love mad magazine so the cartoonists
that I grew up emulating were coming out
of a whole different place than up to
that point and I had to go back and
learn about the labor cartoonists
because of a red-baiting era that they
have you never taught there was no class
when I was taking in high school called
radical car tuning in the labor movement
you know even though I grew up in a
working-class town and the schools were
built by working class taxes and the
teachers were employed but there was no
curriculum that taught labor history
other two other than you know very
quickly and
short as part of capitalism kind of yes
Joel yeah could you please take it up
other words that Fred right that somehow
animated cartoons and I wondering if any
other cartoonists did and related
question is with Vienna now it seems
like that's an avenue that could be
explored and I'm wondering if any
artists are going yeah in general um the
cartoonists can get all the free work
they ever want anytime they want so
animation is is intensive work and and
there really aren't enough venues for it
right now but there are a cartoonist
just what the last three Pulitzer 'he's
were rewarded in part to animation and
the last mark for your won the pulitzer
and all he does is animation and you can
find his work he I mean there's a lot of
cartoonists that qualified to be in this
show but Paul told me if I ran over a
certain time that he would pull the plug
or make me wear his leather jacket I
can't remember Hollywood yes what you
said yes I was curious I you mentioned
slightly like the powers in
collaboration with a driver
that started in what is like the
audience or the athlete inside of that
oh the future of cartooning I mean it's
obviously not up to me I mean I'm going
to 10 you an age and eventually die so
the future is going to be whatever the
cartoonists drawing now make it so
certainly graphic novels are a very
important part of the current cartooning
scene there's all kinds of multi-panel
cartooning being done by quite a few
very accomplished cartoonists they they
tend to move within this world of
self-reflection and analyzing everyday
life and then moving in politics but not
right not not sort of sort of like the
way the the young waffen are and should
be they sort of keep a handout in and
see all of the older generation is being
corrupted and so they have to find their
own way and find their own way to
express that and and I'm sure that that
will happen I only know what I know so
that's what I present so
laughing yeah Paul butyl who also worked
on my comp at me house in book and also
the song history of the SDS and he's
very perfect but yes yes he tell us
about some of the manual quits in your
life that led you to make the decision
to what doing Jamie no a successful
passion and i mentioned i brought the in
particular error but really promoted
their pop yeah well I come from white
trash my mother grew up dirt poor
literally my father was a machinist but
he also was a labor activist and
president of his Union and I grew up in
a working-class city Racine Wisconsin
which is a shadow of itself and one time
I racine had more union members than any
city in the I states per capita so and
it was a great place to grow up and we
had a population of right around 250,000
when when I was a child and there were
lots of parks and free zoo and very good
schools and it was because people made
good money and they pay taxes and those
taxes built a nice little town so it was
my people the proud white trash that
that built that so when I was
radicalized during the Vietnam era like
lot of cartoonists but I always had this
working-class approach to it that the
the anti-war movement was on I think
cruel to drafted soldiers who really had
very limited choices about how they were
going to live their lives and so I had a
very working-class perspective my entire
life and when and Mike Connor Peggy and
I we often talk about this there was
there was a time when when we looked at
our cartoons and we knew they were
different than what other cartoonists
were doing and we didn't know we were
doing labor cartoons but we were so we
had to find out what labor cartoons were
and and and then the opportunity came
for both of us Mike started drawing for
a strike paper in Madison Wisconsin and
I started drawing for a teacher's union
and racine during a the one of the
longest teachers strikes in the history
of the United States and so on and that
work started being picked up by other
labor publications and as Mike said we
we filled a void and got sucked in and
and that's kind of true and and I mean
the the opportunity I have today due to
draw for the ue was I mean it surprised
me as much as it probably surprised that
you e but it was a it was a privilege I
never would imagine what happened to me
so I just sort of I walked in at a time
when when Fred had been very sick and
the ue was was looking for for
syndicated cartoons and they ran a lot
of mike and my cartoons & and i attended
a convention in Milwaukee and I met
this young woman who had just been
elected the first secretary treasurer of
industrial union in America and and
peter gilmore who's sitting here
introduced me and she said hi I'm Amy
Newell how would you like to be the
cartoonist for the ue and that was a
very long time ago now so but yeah I
mean I don't know how to say it but i
don't feel right if i'm not in this
struggle I mean this and and and and it
doesn't matter that most people in this
country see the labor movement as almost
non-existent much of what's good about
this country came from a very strong
labor movement and that's just a fact
and the fact is majority of people in
this country are workers right we talk
all the time television talks all the
time about the middle class and people
live in New York and sitcoms and they
have apartments that anybody who's ever
lived in New York knows those people
couldn't afford on the jobs they have
but television is selling the concept of
the middle class walmart sells you the
concept of the middle class okay you
can't afford your lifestyle but walmart
now is made it affordable for you again
and you can keep buying all this crap to
fill your life and convince yourself
that you're not a lowly worker but you
know what folks you are so
wait I actually Socialist Party during
progressive era and I like to be served
with fava beans and one thing I heard of
since I was started to to my research is
when I was looking for novels written by
wobbly they don't exist um and yet
you're right there was like a
snappamatic cultural production that
they did and so I was wondering if you
had any feelings or insights or thought
you know why cartoony and might have
been a kind of medium of choice for them
based on their yeah well I mean
cartooning was much more like activism
right so you you're not going to
organize a bunch of minors with a novel
you know there you go on your way going
to read this on the way home you know
well but cartooning can speak work more
directly although it really it saddens
my heart to hear that the novel's don't
exist did you try calling the Charles
Kerr company and Chicago you did and
they just don't have no that's cuz in
Charlie mcalister's of Labor historian
you happen to be sitting next to a labor
historian as a matter of fact you could
probably throw a rock and hit a labor of
story in this room okay anything else
I'm really enjoying the question and the
answers but Paul tells me have to give
the room back in in five minutes though
you said 730 so that's that wait doing a
conversation I'm sure you know in an arm
chance to leave yeah yeah yeah yeahs
leave if you must thank you for coming
very much I appreciate it